I'm gonna pull up this story here from
U.S news fears about World War III are
growing amid Russia Ukraine war survey
fines
gee I wonder why well the pope said we
are in World War III but this is
interesting stuff
they said uh Russia oh here we go look
at this Russia's unprovoked war with
Ukraine and I'm just like is this an
op-ed or is it a survey okay the
provocation for people to get references
like if Russia had a military base and
this is what Dave Smith said again in
Montreal and they were just they took it
over and then they were establishing
military forces and long-range missiles
in Montreal and then for us to go in and
be like no no no we're taking it back
we're liberating it that would have been
and to say that it was unprovoked of us
to go back into my to go into Montreal
when Russia had been building up there
that's provocation right I want to read
the story they say in a survey of more
than seventy thousand people across the
world three quarters of respondents
agreed with the statement I fear we are
moving closer to World War III the
findings are called from the U.S news
and World Report best country survey
yada yada it's from April 30th to July
13th this survey was done before all of
this went down the craziest part is this
eighty percent of those in five
countries Indonesia South Korea Spain
Thailand and the US believed that we are
heading towards a global war those
surveyed within the age range of 25 to
35 were the most fearful with 76
worrying about Nations moving closer to
another global conflict
so
you know what
what I think about when I see this
we always we always read history and
it's condensed and now we don't know
which direction things will go but I
suppose the question I have is are
things de-escalating the answer the
answer is a resounding no especially
with NATO saying we will as a collective
respond to an attack on our
infrastructure which here's what I think
it sounds like what they're saying
NATO forces Western forces Western
aligned interest uh interests destroyed
the pipeline
and that statement was Russia if you
retaliate we will go to war with you
that's exactly what it was and and and
them trotting out Biden having said this
just a few months ago that if if they
invade Ukraine we're going to get the
pipeline they can point it right back at
us and he gave them that's another
example of not having a president that
knows what he's saying when he's saying
yeah well before you know the president
said it the deputy secretary of state
Victoria Newland said this I just did a
video about her she's a fascinating
human being she's known as the kind of
uh the the lady of the neoconservatives
Miss Dick Cheney light she served under
uh Dick Cheney during the Iraq War she
had her hand in almost every single U.S
Global intervention in the past 30 years
and she said in January that if Russia
invades Ukraine Russia will not be
having the nordstream 2 pipeline one way
or another yeah and then and then uh
Biden came out and I think think made
that particular statement that that
you're referring to no no no no Newland
said one way or another there will not
be a nordstream pipeline and uh and Joe
Biden said there will not be
a Nord stream if Russia invades Ukraine
then our reporter follows up and says
how will you do this controlled by
Germany and he says uh I promise you we
will get it done and I guess marks yeah
and and this is earlier this year right
right before the invasion right before
the war and even Salon came out and
wrote an article saying how appointing
Victoria Newland to Obama's foreign
policy team was quote a really bad idea
if she's going to be a key player in his
foreign policy because it's a high risk
to everyone so even Salon even leftist
news organizations were saying hey
please let's not appoint her to
positions of power because this is going
to lead to chaos this is going to lead
to war she literally had her hand in
almost every single conflict the last 30
years and for her to to still be calling
the shots she's also known as the lady
that was organizing protests and working
as a diplomat overseeing the Ukrainian
revolution in 2014. I did a full video
about this it's fascinating to see her
hand in this entire conflict from the
very beginning pushing the envelope and
I think we're we're reaching a situation
where that envelope is about to fall off
of the table uh because she is really
going for it when it comes to
instituting American policy that has put
us on this pathway since 2014 that is
extremely dangerous for everyone here
here's a question that I have when it
comes to this stuff
is it worth war with Russia question
what do you think is is any of this
worth the potential of a nuclear war no
no none of it's worth it to us now hold
on so let me ask you a question let's uh
localize the conflict wokeness all right
uh we're in a culture War something that
we are particularly worried about
is it worth the culture War to stop what
they're doing to kids in the
indoctrination yes even if it leads to
Civil War even if it leads to Civil War
if if we are looking down the barrel of
overt Civil War
is there a point where you would say I
accept I am willing to lay down my arms
to prevent War knowing that it means the
woke people will win and their gender
ideology and the things that happen
happening with kids will increase
tenfold would you lay down you know no
well I think I think when you're talking
about innocence when you're talking
about innocent children and and what
what adults want to go to this and then
there's a line there you know there's a
there's a moral line where you can say
no I'm not I'm going to pick up my arms
right so my point is not to in any way
insinuate people should be fighting they
shouldn't be it's a question of when
when we localize the issues that we care
about when we think about in the context
of something that we're directly you
know more directly concerned about we as
people
um you know living and working in the
United States and very focused on
domestic issues we don't know the full
scale of the war
what we do know is that I don't want to
die for whatever BS they're working on
with Ukraine right
the issue I suppose is understanding
that feeling you have of I will not I
will not back down in this culture war
in in this political battle with what
the left is doing with all this work
ideology stuff they won't the same is
true for what the US and Russia are
doing it's it's a question that you can
go to Western intelligence say is it
really worth it why don't you just let
Russia do their thing because otherwise
we have nuclear war and they're going to
say we will not stand for this Russia
will be asked the same question
absolutely not we will never lay down
our arms
and then it's just dominoes falling over
where you and everyone ends up losing
it's a pissing contest everyone just
covered in Piss but what what is the US
goal here I mean because I think I think
the Russian goal is at least a bit more
plainly clear they don't want to see
just like they agreed to in 2014. the
build up in Ukraine right where that way
it's way more complicated you know well
I know I know it's more complicated
Russia's trying to rebuild the Soviet
Union basically yeah I know that yeah I
know but what is and so the goal of the
United States is to keep that from
happening right and and and partly
because gas prom controls most of the
pipelines talking to you I think they
really want the Soviet Union back again
oh Putin's talked about it yeah but he
just we just went and sat down with um
who was he sitting down with and he was
like he said something like remember who
you uh work for or something like that I
can't remember yeah he Putin also sees
NATO as a legitimate threat against
Russia and its people as well as well as
trying to bring back the old kind of
Soviet Empire as well so we have to
understand that also the larger
geopolitical picture is complicated
because of the new energy X exploration
that has been done in the southern coast
of Ukraine that has found that Ukraine
could soon become a major major Petro
state if Ukraine becomes a major Petro
State the one leverage that Russia has
in all of Europe is totally gone they
will have a competitor on its doorsteps
that will also house a lot of its troops
that they see as someone that will
potentially invade them in the future so
there's a lot of things happening here
behind the scenes there's a lot of
things geopolitically also with energy
policy that people need to understand
and it's far more complicated than just
unprovoked attacked it's not just that
there's Freedom involved here they hate
us for our freedom exactly I think the
goal is like Global Security if you had
to ask what's the U.S goal here not as
much not the the number one top goal
isn't just prevent the Soviet Union from
forming it's Global Security and part of
doing that is to prevent a Soviet Union
but honestly we need to police ourselves
and we can do that with Russia as a
Federation of states of people like
they're just people like us they have a
red white and blue flag they broke up a
crazy dick-tocratic State uh just like
we got out of the the kingdom of England
uh we're in this together we're not we
are as people on Earth breathing the
same air and drinking the same water you
have people who fundamentally view the
world differently than each other and
there is no reconciling well that will
always be the case and that's view it
differently reconciliation is do we want
you live you just deal with it that's
what we've done for 250 years you don't
right now there are uyghur concentration
camps in China we do not lay down and
accept what China's people we are no we
have for like a decade the United States
is is is is doing what they can I
suppose without with with trying to
avoid war this is the point I'm trying
to make with even Civil War in the
United States we don't want to fight
yeah we don't want people to die but we
need this to stop so we're constantly
clashing with opposing forces that view
the world fundamentally differently than
we do and there is no just stopping and
saying you know what we're all people
China why don't you just forcibly rape
those women and you want to learn the
language
whole America first thing is ridiculous
this old line of demarcation calling us
the West it's all British Centric like
come on you got to learn Russian and
Mandarin if we want to if we want to
peacefully resolve this stuff well that
is there is a good point there because I
name name a Chinese Diplomat that
doesn't know English you know what I
mean that that's something I've always
thought about when you're when you're
talking about speaking I I worked with
Chinese students for example they knew
exactly what I was saying when I was
saying it how I was saying the
connotation you know the the things
behind it and when they would speak
nothing and and when they would try to
translate some of their things uh some
of the things they would say in their
language to me I couldn't quite get what
they were saying and they knew it and
that that that is that is a good point
that we need to maybe Branch out at
least our understanding of what other
languages we're speaking so we can make
an attempt at least to try to understand
where they're coming from but that
doesn't mean we can accept ever that
that you know uh atrocities that that
are that's like going on in China with
with the uyghurs and with the women that
they abuse and with I mean there's
videos of them running over running over
old women in in tanks and things like
that it's just but at the same time you
know the Chinese are answering back like
okay you're making these accusations
against concentration camps what about
what you did in gitmo what about the CIA
rendition programs and we're seeing
Chinese diplomats answer answer that
back and at least American policy should
exemplify and practice the principles
that it preaches to bring on to other
people and then those arguments would be
more legitimate but of course there is a
lot of criticism when it comes to
foreign policy when it comes to the
military-industrial complex when it
comes to corporations and private
industries that have been creating
massive amounts of human rights
violations especially in Yemen
especially all over the the Middle East
that again should be called out as well
stopped immediately if we're going to be
lecturing other countries about human
rights but rest easy my good friend Luke
because right now we can all huddle up
to the warm bosom of Joe Biden knowing
that with his strength America will not
be defeated thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there